isn't this a prediction another miracle
in the quran where god almighty allah is
talking about a prophecy something will
happen in the future why
you would want that to influence your
child
would you want a stripper or a porn star
to influence your child
[Music]
i am a wolf therian and a member of the
furry fandom
[Music]
thank you for tuning in to the dean show
now my next guest dr kareem abu zaid
is an imam a community leader an expert
in the area of quran exegesis islamic
counselor
leadership and development role amongst
other areas of expertise and we are
bringing him on to get his reaction to
some of the current events
that are happening around us and to see
if he can answer
the million-dollar question what is a
woman what is a man
another important questions but first
let us open up
with this committee meeting that was
happening that took place and the person
speaking his name is matt walsh from the
film what
is a woman i would thank you all for
allowing me to speak to you tonight but
you try not to allow it yet here i am
now you only give us 60 seconds so let
me get to the point you are all child
abusers you prey upon impressionable
children and indoctrinate them into your
insane ideological cult a cult which
holds many fanatical views but none so
deranged as the idea that boys or girls
and girls are boys by imposing this vile
nonsense on students to the point even
of forcing young girls to share locker
rooms with boys you deprive these kids
of safety and privacy and something more
fundamental too which is truth if
education is not grounded in truth then
it is worthless worse it is poison you
are poison you are predators i can see
why you try to stop us from speaking you
know that your ideas are indefensible
you silence the opposing side because
you have no argument you can only hide
under your beds like pathetic little
gutless cowards hoping we shut up and go
away but we won't
i promise you that
thank you for your time and i'll talk to
you again very very soon jake kareem abu
zayed how are you doing shane hey how
are you doing good good to see you again
man good to see you again
did you get a chance to see the opening
yeah
you know
alhamdulillah
rasulullah
[Music]
[Music]
a lot of people don't realize that
the subject of
uh you know homosexuality
is
addressed thoroughly
in the quranic
scripture
and actually
it's built on the
uh mosaic tradition as well which is the
old testament the book of genesis and so
forth
that the jews and christians go by right
yes
although the literature we believe that
it has been affected by the human inputs
in fusions there but still
reads out that this is wrong
what a lot of muslims don't realize that
those individuals
who
adopt this lifestyle
they are not going to stop
until they tell you what they told luth
and his family get out of here
that's that's their their agenda that's
their end of of of flying agenda
this is in the quran
expel the family of loot
out of the
your town because
they are
abducting purity which is the in a way
they are admitting that
what they are doing is impure
um
so stop right there shay you know it
says and his people did not answer him
but this they said drive them out of
your city these are indeed men who want
to be that's the key words they want to
be pure clean and pure moral
[Laughter]
so
this this is the ayah that you're
sharing with us yes
this is from the verbatim word of god
almighty the creator of allah yeah and
that's the words the god the god of
jesus i mean the god of jesus the god of
the christians the god of the jews the
god of humanity allah said that on their
tongue that's what they said so allah
said that on their tongue in our
revelation
so because they want to live a clean
pure life now they're under attack
absolutely
so a lot of a lot of muslims especially
the so-called uh self-claimed leaders of
this community especially in the usa
they come up and say well let's align
because they are no that's not their
agenda
you know you know eddie uh we we have a
doctrine in islam called the doctrine of
which is loyalty and disavow
basically you're not supposed to
accept or
like what people do of polytheism of
shrink
but yet
you still need to treat them with
respect justly and fairly and kindly as
long as they are not combatant that's
the overall um
you know
a christian a devout christian will
respect you being a muslim
and he will settle for that just like
pastor david when i visited yes yes but
those people they will not leave you
alone unless you join their party
and you know
and you need to there was a video there
was a video out there with circuit did
you see it we're coming to get your kids
we're coming to get your kids
did you see that that's that agenda and
that is why those people who say oh oh
don't don't don't don't say no or yes we
got to get some guy saying that
just just stay in the middle don't say
that's the the crime of the wife of
prophet luth
what was her crime she was in the middle
you know
don't assume that she was astounded for
allah a lesbian never allah will test a
messenger with with such a trial no
her crime is she consented
she did not say yes she did not say no
but let me let me just you know you got
me off guard here because i really
wanted to start from somewhere eddie
so many places in the quran allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala speaks about
previous nations and their defiance and
their rebellious the rebellion the
rebellious attitudes towards the
messengers and the prophets
and normally allah would attribute that
they disbelieved they are arrogant they
didn't adhere
really you will find allah subhanahu wa
mentioning a sin
a sin that they actually did
accept to my understanding
maybe
there are others but the most common
issue i cheating
and and and
selling and buying business transactions
and the people who float
when it comes to this immorality immoral
sin which is homosexuality
here is what a lot of muslims do not
know
that
allah wa'ta'ala spoke out against this
in that manner in the quran
because they openly
started doing it
they openly started calling people to it
they openly started going after their
population
and like i mentioned at the very
beginning
look what luke said to them and this
reference
i wish you can bring the reference there
uh
you know that the people who we
were rappers you know the people who who
are up the uh still the the wayfarers
you know the people are traveling
look at this
and you openly commit this sin
in your social clubs in your gathering
is this the verse that you're talking
about remember lewd behold he said to
his people you do commit uh lewdness
such as
uh such as no other creation committed
before do you indeed approach men and
cut off the highway here you go highway
hours yes yeah
and practice wickedness in your councils
but yes it's people
the word
is like a social connection you know
like a social club like where you meet
so you do this openly publicly so we've
gotten muslims need to wake up they got
into that limit they got into that level
now they are at this stage now and they
are inviting us
and and and
that's that's that's the point that's
the point if you if you're doing
something in the privacy of your heart
okay
but why do you have to be identified by
your sexuality now this is like you know
getting out there and promoting this and
trying to especially to the children now
at you're seeing what's happening in the
schools you see how they're bringing
this into the schools at a young age
and they're confusing the children and
they're doing something that now for i
don't know since the beginning of time
you had a boy was a boy a man a girl was
a girl but now they're coming up with
this you know this thing about you have
biology you have dear sex then you have
your gender and gender as they say fluid
it could just like change or
there's no science behind it there is no
uh rationale behind it
uh there's nothing solid behind it but
confusion and you have uh i believe
you saw the dr phil it's real surprising
that he was quoting that half the
country is divided on this half of
americans say they feel very or somewhat
comfortable
using gender-neutral pronouns while 48
say they feel very
or somewhat uncomfortable using them so
if you don't stand for something of
truth that's solid you can see how
people can be swayed because of public
pressure peer pressure social pressure
you know you know who they are targeting
most now muslims yeah you saw the hijab
those why why would they have uh muslim
women this is so sacred whom imitate
married the mother of jesus it's just
like having a yeah and she's
holding a rainbow flag why why do you
need why don't you just portray her
without the hijab no well
what if they had the hot the uh
jewish
rabbis eating pork right
yeah the pork company they were business
was going low and they really wanted to
get uh sales up so they were promoting
pork and they were using the rabbis
eating pork
why why
why that muslims are the last line of
defense you need to understand you
probably saw that the pope uh the
catholic pope the the largest
organized christian uh uh you know
institution in the world
uh came out and he said they are part of
us they are part of the family so
you know other people reformist uh the
people who are called themselves
reformers uh reformist of uh previous uh
faith they already
compromised
i wanna show you something now this is
this is not a woman this is this is a
man so don't uh i know we try to hold
things very modest and whatnot so don't
get spooked out [ __ ] but this is uh
this is a man who's who's coming out
they call it a drag queen so i would ask
would the pope allow this in front of
him would he be a part of this but
because they're having these things with
children so this is the warning
what in the hell has a drag queen ever
done
to make you have so much respect for
them and admire them so much
other than put on makeup and and jump on
the floor and ride around and do sexual
things on stage
i have absolutely no idea
why
you would want that to influence your
child
would you want a stripper or a porn star
to influence your child
it makes no sense at all
a drag queen performs in a nightclub for
adults
there is a lot of filth that goes on a
lot of sexual stuff that goes on
and backstage there's a lot of nudity
sex and drugs
okay so i don't think that this is a
an avenue you would want your child to
explore so they're having children
who are you can't have a child go to a
strip club
uh because you can get arrested for that
right you can be in some deep trouble
but they bring them to these events and
having these children put dollar bills
into these men's
underwear g-strings and this is what and
then they uh next day and also having
the young kids coming and doing this
story hour with uh with this and if you
say anything then then you're labeled uh
certain names derogatory names or
whatever i've been i've been living in
this country for almost uh 30 some years
the last decade there is a huge boost to
that movement we know why
because somehow the equated
the sixties civil rights movements which
defended the rights of the
african-americans
who were discriminated against this
franchise
because of their color
with their rights you see there is an
organization which a lot of muslims go
for black lives matter
you know they
they they got it on the agenda of black
lives matter they basically said okay
let's align with you and whatever
privileges you get we get two and that
is why they got that boost
first of all is it fair to equate the
60s
civil rights movement with them no
these guys they they were discriminated
against because of their color
so now because of a desire that they
have inside them sexual their sexual
sexual orientation is a private thing
eddie is not something that you have
disclosed why do you need to disclose it
unless you're inviting me to it
why do you need to talk about it to
others you can just have it in your la
condino como leading stay away from me
stay away from my family
but like you mentioned no they are not
going to stop there
they are going to whether expelled those
who of course they defame you're a homo
uh folk
some some muslims now lose their job
some businesses go out of business
because of that and it's going to keep
going eddie
those people allah told us in the quran
that they tried
to raid the angels who appeared in a
human form who came to destroy them or
trying to destroy them they actually try
to raid them go after them so this is
this is not going to be like something
out there
you know there is a hadith out there
the prophet said
the likeness of those who stand for what
is right
and those who compromise
you know those those who go and say oh
oh it's a losing you know it's a losing
battle don't do something about it you
know i never heard a scholar
someone who calls himself a scholar
would speak like that in that manner in
that manner you know the prophet says
when you see evil change it with the
hand of course we live in a country we
abide by the laws of the land we cannot
do that okay the tongue
and if you cannot do both then what
separate go away with your heart
condemn it detest it with your heart
what that's what you need to do to be
saved
one of the things that loot is salaam
said to his people eddie and that's in
chapter
i wish you can bring it the context in
chapters
i detest that he said that to them i
abhor that i hate that i hate what you i
hate the act not you they still call
them my brothers you're my brothers
we're going to give them the one but i
hate the act and i condemn it with my
heart because if i don't it's going to
come to me it's going to reach me i'm
going to be one of them soon if you do
not do that eddie so if somebody go
the point i'm sorry the subject really
you know
it gets to me i go back to the hadith
quickly so the prophet said the likeness
of those who stand firm and those who
compromise is like two groups of people
gathering a ship you're familiar
the people downstairs you know they are
well intended we can say that these
brothers who say that the brothers who
go and and and align
with individuals who promote this openly
and because of a common cause
uh justifying this by helpful
or the alliance of the virtuous and the
sierra which has nothing to do with it
we understand that they could be well
intended the brother who said you know
the brother who said that don't do
anything about they were not policing
the the uh or uh uh politically correct
but morally incorrect morally haram
differentiating between the two
they could be well intended but but look
what the prophet told us
you know every time they want water they
go up the upper level and disturb the
people in the upper level the people who
have the knowledge the wisdom the
understanding they see they read the
quran they base their opinions on quran
and sunnah and they understand so the
people in the the
the lower
level of the ship what do they do what
they want to do they want to take a hole
in the ship what will happen to the
whole it's going to get to you brothers
brothers and sisters in islam the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
every newborn is born on the fitra yes
we understand that means islam but
also means trait
identity he's a male
he's a female
now who's responsible for protecting
that fitra you
and they're going after your children in
the public school system listen i'm not
inciting hate or anything no i'm just
telling you
wake up you're the last line of defense
the muslims are the last line of defense
against this immoral
trend in the united states which will
lead to the destruction of this country
brothers and sisters in islam we're
going to end up with two solutions
whether the ship is going to sink with
an s with all of us like in the hadith
or like the people of lou are gonna have
to leave we're gonna have to leave
so so this is where you have because
people and that's one of the slogans
love and that love and all you know
these uh and you quoted this from
university where they also talk about
this play on words right these play on
words and but the real love is what
you're doing here what um muslims are
trying to do as because you you have the
the prophet of mercy as god almighty
allah says you have been sent as a mercy
to all mankind so this is a mercy this
is out of love that you're trying to
protect the people who
from the um what would be called the
medical mafia you know you have people
who are making big business out of this
and you have all the major media outlets
who are programming the minds who are
occupying the hearts and minds of these
young innocent children and you want to
protect people obviously from falling
into which they have studies now that
seven to ten years after these
operations happen you know people this
is the most uh
the group with the most the highest
level of suicide depression
you know some of the most uh amount of
health
problems so this is love it's not
letting someone continue to drink and so
go ahead you're advising them you should
quit you know if you love your friend
then the person's you know on drugs or
an alcoholic you love him so you don't
want him to go down that route
i swear by my lord well as to behind i
say this because i care even for that
community
even for that community
because we know we were firm believers
that
and you have history history you have a
story that is shared
mosaically
biblically
it's in the book of genesis the story
although they added a little bit
extension to it at the end that you know
this is irrelevant here
and you have also the history of the
previous superpowers
what made them decline immorality not
the iphone not the material they were
very progressive material material wise
you know what would be iphone they were
probably going to go until iphone 30 but
you see the decline of morality is going
to drag us down it's gonna take us down
because that's sunnah that's a way of
allah you know that's a universal way of
allah subhanahu wa
and that is why i call upon these
brothers who
somehow
share the platform with those people or
share the platform with someone who
condones that openly
to please come and and retract
correct that because a lot of youth now
are entertaining the idea a lot of youth
consider it part of intolerance no
tolerance you know what tolerance is
tolerance that you call them to the
truth kindly and nicely but in your
heart no i detest that i'm going to say
what lute said in
but you i'm gonna call you kindly i'm
gonna call you nicely to the truth
because i care for you
yeah this is uh really deep if you think
about it uh trying to save people you
know i heard that
each customer that goes down this route
and changes the
the
human biology the parts that law has
given you this is like a 1.3 million
dollars right off the bat over time
that's going to go towards the big uh
drug industry so there's a lot behind
this and when you look at kinsey and
john money and many of these people who
have set the precedence for this who are
the masterminds behind this these were
people who were sick and deranged
pedophiles
yeah sorry go ahead i'm really taken by
that i was uh i don't know if you knew
some of the if you hear some of these
names that psychologists psychiatrists
they go off the works of kinsey the
works of john money these people when
you look at their lives any any sane
person any person who has morality but
that's the part where we have to people
have to go ahead and really
um
because the moral compass if you don't
have that's the thing if you don't have
a guiding light if you're just going off
your wins and desires
then just like half the country is just
uh going along with this because if you
don't stand for something you'll fall
for anything and people are falling for
the biggest trick that shaytan now is
playing on humanity and like you said i
like what you said that now uh some
people are creating more confusion now
they're creating more and more confusion
instead of drawing a firm line and not
being able to deviate from that and this
is true love this is true
mercy the prophet said that the fitna
the test is presented to the heart
if you do not detest it
if you do not abhor it if you do not
hate it i'm not talking about treating
people no
your heart is going to absorb it
art is going to suck it
and sooner sooner and later you're going
to start talking like them acting like
them condoning them accepting them
and so forth and finally you're going to
fall into these traps let's get one of
those right here and i'll get your
reaction so now we are seeing kids that
are identifying as animals going to
school
and they are purring instead of
answering questions and they meow and
the teachers are not allowed to question
it because it's considered a queer
identity
so
you have kids are going to school and
they're saying i'm a cat
and the teachers have to
affirm them as a cat
yes so it's
the literal literal
[Laughter]
i am a 27 year old transgender woman um
i am a wolf therian and a member of the
furry fandom when and how did you
discover this inner wolf-ness um
probably around age 10 or 11. i was
watching an anime about wolves and
see the wolf running across the screen
and i'm somehow just intrinsically like
oh that's me have you spent any time
around biological wolves yes
that sounds dangerous also what context
are you so i was a volunteer with the
preserve and i've also visited many wolf
preserves are you able to communicate
with the wolves am i going to have a
conversation with a wolf in the way that
i'm communicating you and i obviously
not am i going to read their body
language respond appropriately to their
behaviors and their nonverbal cues yes
would you would you be able to give us
an example of
this wolf communication um no
i'm not comfortable doing so okay let me
ask you since you're an expert here in
exeter jesus uh taxier explanation of
the quran isn't this a miracle one of
the miracles there's so many miracles in
the quran for any sincere person that
looks into it the preservation of the
quran the prophecies the science so many
too many lists we're not talking about
that today but isn't this a prediction
another miracle in the quran where god
almighty allah is talking about a
prophecy something will happen in the
future that they will change
that shaitaan will go ahead and entice
them to change the creation of god allah
[Music]
[Music]
you see
four steps here in the first four steps
i i hope you can see i think 196 191 if
i'm not mistaken
196 i think 19191 uh chapter four look
at this the first one anthro misguidance
the confusion you know one of the
smartest i'm not saying this brace
worthy but
the satanic you said uh
19196 if i'm not mistaken
is is is to confuse people is is you
know you go out there and you say well
it's morally haram you see that it's
morally haram
but politically no
what is the difference between the two
this is insane
for a student of knowledge for someone
who
has abc quran abc sunnah
to speak like that
what is the difference between the two
because they are supporting my my cause
defending me again islamophobia so
that's what's happening you begin
feeling cozy about it you feel
comfortable about oh that group is being
uh
treated and thirdly i gotta stand with
them they are like me they are minority
they they are you just mentioned at the
beginning of the show that they reach
half of the country now i i don't know
if this is like the uh the people yeah
well it's from the dr phil show yeah
whatever it is so what is the next
i will make them desired
and once they get to that level i will
command them to change the way that
allah created them to change that fit
which mentioned in the hadith but that's
the quran that's what allah is telling
you why don't we believe our revelation
guys why do we try to employ
our intellect
allah subhanahu wa says
and allah wants you to repent
so that he will accept your repentance
just go ahead and come back to allah
even i want to say this even to the
people who committed that sin
do you still have a chance with allah
you have a chance come back
come back to allah
and those who
follow their whims and desires this is
in the quran the same chapter by the way
those who follow their whims and desires
they want you to go more farther into a
great
greater the greatest deviation that you
can you can reach at so we need to
believe our revelation back off guys we
need to stand firm in the face of this
otherwise i'm telling you whether allah
is going to destroy this nation
and i'm saying it bluntly
and we're going to be destroyed with
them
or whether we're going to have to leave
because we cannot protect ourselves and
protect our children listen guys don't
force me or identify me
because i cannot condone or accept a
desire that you have inside your body
your sexual entrepreneurs between you
and yourself
don't engage me into that and don't
engage my kids either don't engage my
kids either that's that's
that's where you have uh so many
christians so many uh uh orthodox jews
so many people who
uh have
a moral code that they should be living
by they also object to this and this is
something that
so many people are coming up and
speaking out because they're going after
the kids they're going after the kids
and people now you can you you know as a
muslim we can't force someone nor can
someone force us to wear a symbol let's
say if there was a symbol of islam and
we're forcing someone to wear it no one
can force you to put a cross on if
you're not christian and forcing someone
to put a rainbow flag or to put it on
the kids paint paint face on the kids
you know forcing your ideology your
beliefs your sexuality that's oppression
that's wrong you know so that's what
it's unfair to me
and and you accuse me of being
intolerant and here you are you're
practicing top of the line
yeah so you had at one point with the
p at one point with the inquisitions and
whatnot you had people forcing people
let's say to eat pork so you're forcing
people to understand that no you can't
force someone to eat pork if they're a
jew or muslim you can't do that and now
if you're on the contrary you're forcing
someone into
accepting certain things that go against
their moral code to go against
is hateful and what not they just want
to be left alone they just want to live
a peaceful life they're not trying to
harm you
you be yours to be honest respect
respect my respect you allow me to send
a message
to the learned brothers
so-called scholars or self-claimed
leaders of this community and i'm not
going to name them you know i i'm okay
with that
but allow me just a couple of minutes
one of the names of the quran eddie
alfor khan you know what for panics
the dividing
the decisive element or factor between
good and evil
and
actually there is a whole chapter in the
quran called for khan which is chapter
25. if you read that chapter thoroughly
throughout
you will find out that always the
immediate recipients of the revelation
the arabs in mecca
they always it's a mecca chapter they
always requested
a physical sign like that the stick of
musa
or or jesus you know they wanted
something
although the prophet saws elements some
scholars counted 1500
physical signs
you know physical miracles miracles that
you can see
but yet allah subhanahu wa
always responded to them the quran is
the miracle
here is the mistake that a lot of
muslims don't pay attention to
a lot of muslims think that the quran is
miraculous because of a mystic kind of
thing and that's why they go after this
hadith if you saw a chapter you seen 10
times you're going to jump up and down
you're going no no no no no you know why
the quran is a miracle
because it will always stay
a decisive factor between good and evil
not only that
it will produce generations of muslims
who will
present that for khan on the ground and
i wanted to read the last two pages in
this chapter it talks about
man
you see you're asking for a physical
miracle no the miracle of the quran that
it will produce people who will explain
the truth to the people who are not
going to mix this with that and because
this is politically correct and this is
morally incorrect
brothers and sisters in islam back off
don't take
you know people with you
you you can't do that don't especially
the youth they use your fan your fans
the people who sign up for your
facebook page and you become happy when
it reaches a million or two be careful
brothers and sisters in islam come back
and
correct what you have done say this is
wrong publicly and and correct that
because we need to stand together eddie
we need to stand together in the face of
this we cannot break up
if we break up they will eat you and
that's the whole thing if we have some
people who are already compromising the
issue so we need to stand together so
come back to the quran and sunnah and
stat firm and we're not inciting any
hate or any uh
violence here no we're just asking to
protect ourselves and our children
i think we're entitled to that
we are
uh
followers
of divine revelation
which promotes
uh objective morality bound to the
revelation
it's not
it's not standing on a shifting sand
because of democracy and because
somebody passed a law no we're standing
in a firm solid ground
and please leave us alone leave us alone
and brothers and sisters dear muslim
scholars whoever you are whatever you
want to call yourself come back come
back to the truth and don't shy away
because it could be late
if you are the reason for a muslim to go
astray
with regard to this particular facia
particular sin
we got a few we got a little more time
before we come to an end a
close i just want to get
a couple more things in one thing i
thought was very interesting was i
interviewed a conservative christian not
too long ago and these are his words he
said that more and more christians
putting a a stop to the degeneracy and
in the stricter muslim countries they
put their foot down hard where in
america they there it's almost like they
don't put their foot down at all so i
think there's this new respect for islam
and uh in even the christian and
american world that are having a more
favorable view of islam because islam
doesn't bend they're seeing all this
that's happening you know with the kids
going to these uh
getting these lap dances and all the
other madness that's out there the
howling the wolves and you know i'm a
cat and i'm this and i'm a wolf and all
the other madness and they are seeing
when they look into islam that islam
doesn't bend to these things they're
seeing the firmness of it and they're
starting to understand the hikman the
wisdom and this is what the christians
are saying so the last line of defense
this is this is a verse that came
right after the story of loot not right
after but maybe a couple of pages
and in essence allah mentioned the
stories of multiple nations and then
allah is talking to us has it been for
the few who enjoying what is good and
forbid what is evil everybody would have
been destroyed like us you see they want
us to compromise and you're the last
line of defense and that is why i feel
so sad and when you know i feel so sad
when i see someone who calls himself a
scholar stealing
his followers
don't condem don't accept stay in the
middle what do you mean
this is you're asking us to abduct the
position of the wife of luke my friend
and and that's
allah made her a sign for humanity until
the day of judgment
when they when prophet luth was leaving
town she turned into a stone an idol in
order to become
a crystal clear sign to show you
the
uh uh
the destiny
and the uh
the recombins of those
who
not accept it not practice it no no
those who stand in the middle no you got
to make your position crystal clear but
eddie if you allow me
because one of the tactics
uh which the
this group uses
you know they want to be all-inclusive
so anybody who has the thought of
becoming a you know homosexual he has
some that internal attraction so they
include him they want to defend him i
tell you brother you could have these
attractions to the same gender it is
possible shaytan may play on you but
you're not a gay you're not a homosexual
no you're not because you have not done
it and by the way the respected brothers
and sisters in islam you striving not to
respond to that call internal call you
get so much reward from allah subhanahu
wa
you know sometimes eddie
we normally talk about individuals who
get rewarded for doing good deeds but we
do not talk about those who stay away
from the
the three individuals who got stranded
inside a cave right you're familiar with
that hadith right and they couldn't come
out right what is the second man was
doing what is the second man did
he was invited to adulth
and he said i love her i love her
i never he said that i never loved the
woman the way that i loved my cousin
but i feel when she reminded me of allah
i fear the law and imagine this act move
the rock move the rack made the rock
move eddie when you stand in the face of
your desire there is nothing wrong with
having these feelings
eddie they normally come up with this
idea that these are jeans no give me a
break you know
i'm going to use an analogy here
a couple of hadith that individuals came
to the prophet and said yeah rasulallah
we find cure in grapes which turns into
liquor
like these days we have the medical
marijuana by the way this is something
also we should stand for because we're
going to come to our kids anything that
is immoral we're going to stand for
another said well this particular thing
which intoxicates we find cure in it you
know what allah what the prophet said to
them allah is more wise to place a cure
in something that he made a lawful so
you think when when you when you say
that you have genes these are because of
the way that you were created you're
accusing allah his wisdom you don't know
anything about allah i'm telling you if
you say that anybody and and not only
that medical people came up with
research
lab work
proving that this has nothing to do with
the way that you were born yeah this was
a hoax yeah this is a horse
it has nothing to do with it yes there
are some individuals who are born with
some more hormones in this area we
understand that and that's why they have
this attraction but you know if if
may allah protect me from that imagine
you're loving the wife of another muslim
brother and you love her you know that
love for love
that hollywood love not not the islam
huh so does this justify you go after
her and try to marry her and divorce her
from her husband huh no i'm sorry for
allah i'm not gonna do that although i
love her but i'm not gonna do that i'm
not gonna respond this is where we're
tested i love money i love money we all
have excess extra hormones in some area
i love money that means i go and break
into wells fargo and and do a bank
robbery here no how about how about the
brother shake he says look i got four i
want five
you also have so many doctors you have
uh and we're almost out of time but just
to touch upon this you know you had some
some scholars who talked about the
pathogenic diseases that this promotes
and cdc and others have warned about
uh sodomy in this particular area that
the harms that are potentially created
that can happen so this is another area
that doctors you know people who talk
about heart disease they talk about you
know so many other health disasters that
can happen if you eat this kind of fatty
food this that any other but here you
have medical experts they're scared to
speak up but many have in the literature
but they're scared to come out because
what happens they will get ostracized
they'll get attacked so this is another
point yeah uh uh just one more thing
sheikh before we come out can i just
complete this this story yes please
sorry about it in context
brothers and sisters in islam
uh some people may end up uh
contemplating uh considering this
same uh or that homosexuality because of
an experience that they had as a
children whether they fallen into it
because they didn't know the gravity of
it or whether they were molested or
raped we understand that these are the
reasons why that's a big reason yeah yes
these are the reasons but again this is
your test brothers life is only 67 years
old they're not going to be done the
test is going to be over the test is
going to be over and you have janna
stand firm don't allow these internal
struggles that you had in the past
affect
your religion affect your islam
one last thing brother eddie you have
two types here the one type who had
allies this
and those are the people of sodom and
gomorrah
the people who believe that this is
lawful this is so insa and we still have
those who have fallen into it or they
have tendency towards it but they still
believe it's a sin stay like this at
least
and come out of it for the sake of allah
but those
who
had allies did made it lawful
then they have gone out of the fold of
islam although there is nothing we can
do but
uh we need also to throw the ground
because we want people to contemplate
the idea that slowfall allah made me
this way that is wrong there is no such
a thing
one brother mustafa he gives a an
example of a story and it goes relates
to coming back there was a woman
who came to one of his lectures and he
was presenting islam giving the evidence
and the proofs etc etc and then the
person he saw
this lady there with another lady
they're holding hands and
later he found out that they were a
couple
and then he just intrinsic he thought
that there's no way that this person
would you know accept islam because x y
z but later come to know this person
actually after his lecture after some
time looking into the proofs and
evidences that person came back to god
to allah they accepted islam and then in
the conversation the person said that
look prayer i didn't have a hard time
establishing it i got it down hijab
i got that taken care of
this was my biggest test this attraction
to the opposite uh to the same
but
i did it for god i did it for allah and
i overcame it
so this
is this is a true story
if you leave something for the sake of
allah for allah allah will support you
and allah will give you something much
much much better
and there are certain things since
or certain trials eddie the only one who
can save you is allah and this is one of
them i'm telling you this is one of them
and that is why i call upon every muslim
who found himself in that area
you know uh eddie by the way luth was
not raised up in these seven sodom and
gomorrah towns you're probably aware of
that you know luther
so he was sent to those people he was
not one of them
he was not like a but yet
uh
uh
you are my brethren
you know he's calling these people you
are my brethren you know yes we gotta
have that attitude we gotta call these
brothers and these sisters especially
muslims who are have fallen into the
dungeons of
of this wicked lewdness
you still have a chance
but
don't
pass the line of halalization that you
begin contemplating the idea it's lawful
to do that because the moment that you
pass that line
it's over
uh we're almost out of time but you have
a certain politician muslim politician
i don't have to say the lady's name but
she's also
kind of just went towards that avenue of
what you're saying this is very very um
inappropriate for someone who is all
upon every muslim
i care for you and i know who you're
talking about dear sister back off
your asherah
is more important you're here after is
more important than a seat in a congress
or a seat in a senate or whatever it is
than a podium in
i get invited so many places i always
ask who's with me
on that platform
because i know that the moment that i
associate myself
that it that sends a message sends a
message
so i also call upon these
big so-called self-claimed leaders check
out who you hang around with on public
because it sends a message
yes
it may not be a direct one but indirect
one and you don't want to be a reason
for the misguidance
and i call upon these brothers and
sisters who are firm on this and they
are facing a lot
remember
of the creation of the quran
and everybody was compromising
everybody was giving in even his uncle
came to him and he said to him yeah
tell them what they want to hear yet me
they are flocking you said no i can't do
that
you know especially if you're a schooler
especially if you're
if you're someone who has
five six million people in your fan and
facebook page one million two million
one hundred two hundred
stand firm for the truth broadcast the
right message so that allah will save
your followers
for addressing them
last
last thing i want to ask you is the
that's the million-dollar question this
is uh
something that hopefully you can answer
because
this individual matt walsh she went out
from the movie what is a woman and he
was asking these are academics you know
these are specialists in the field what
is a woman so how would you answer that
question what is a woman what is a man
you see that's that's the uh entry to
entertaining this this ideology the
entire package you see it's a whole
package
it begins by that tolerance accepting
them how are you doing you know being
around them and then actually you know
you know how the whole thing started is
trying to give
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala not he
cancelling out allah is he
you understand
when they start questioning that and and
the inequality between you see this old
shaitaan shaitan shaitaan brothers and
sisters in islam
allah created you
to be tested in this world
and this is a serious
area
you know we have been talking about it
light in the past because it was hidden
in the bedroom somewhere but now they
are coming after you coming after your
children we're not inciting hate again a
disclaimer because people like to you
know jump on that kind of talk no
but
make sure that you do something in your
area to defend your children
i hope you will consider sending your
children to salahuddin future academy
online instead of public school
i and by the way we're going to be
opening inshaallah
a center in in florida where the deen
center is so i'm putting you on the spot
now
and i'm calling abunda brothers and
sisters help us out meet our target i'm
going to come out heavy with the with
fundraising for the dean center in in
florida insha'allah salahuddin future
academy will be part of that we're going
to establish a school there in florida
one of the branches but alhamdulillah it
is children actually are enrolled in
salahuddin future academy which is a
national school brothers and sisters in
islam your children cannot afford losing
tawheed and morality objective morality
and that's what's happening in the
public school now we're presenting to
you the alternative enroll your children
help us expand this
thank you very much for sharing this
time with us may god
and thank you guys for tuning in here to
the dean show very very important topic
get your kids out of public schools and
you have an alternative there with the
uh salahuddin academy
and continue for anybody that's gone
down that route you see the door of
mercy is always open the love is there
god almighty is the most merciful love
and turn back to the creator heavens and
earth think and contemplate what's the
purpose of life why am i here deaf is
approaching am i going to follow my
whims and desires and my fancies and
be in the land of confusion get out of
the confusion look into islam and we
have a gift for you
visit the deanshow.com get a free copy
of the quran and start with that formula
ask if you ask you shall receive ask
sincerely the creator of heavens and
earth guide me guide me guide me and
inshallah god willing he will god he's
the most loving the most merciful and
we'll see you next time here on the
dean's show until then peace be with you
assalamu alaikum i cannot leave without
giving you a gift if you're not yet
muslim and you're tuning in to see what
these muslims are talking about and you
like a free copy of the quran go and
visit the deenshow.com we'll take care
of the postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions
about islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you assalamu
alaikum and if you like this episode of
the dean show
like this video
share this video
far and wide and support us on our
patreon page so we can continue this
work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum brothers and
sisters we're halfway there this is your
brother eddie from the dean show and
alhamdulillah we are purchasing a 35 000
square foot property to build the dean
center a dawa center a masjid the first
of its kind in america and we are
halfway there to closing on the property
we have 700 000 left that must be
collected this month in order to close
on the property get the tremendous
rewards by helping to build the dean's
center with us by donating right now may
god almighty allah reward all of you